[موسيقى]
ليس سرا ان الملك تشارز الثالث اقام
علاقات وثيقه مع العائلات الحاكمه في دول
الخليج ودول عربيه اخرى منذ عقود فعلى
مدار سنوات زار الملك تشارت عشره دوله
عربيه عده مرات
ركزت بشكل اساسي على تعزيز روابط بريطانيا
بها وبناء الثقه وفي طابعتها السعوديه
التي حل ضيفا عليها 10 مرات والتقى مع
قادتها بدءا من الملك فهد والملك عبد الله
الى الملك سلمان وولي عهده لارساء التواصل
بين مسؤول البلدين على اعلى المستويات
والحفاظ على الطابع الشخصي للعلاقات
اعتقد ان هذه الروابط ستستمر وعندما يقول
احدهم انه كان يقيم تلك العلاقات فاراها
انها اتت بشكل طبيعي من شخص كان مهتما حقا
بما قراه وما لاحظه بالاضافه الى انه شخص
عميق التفكير للغايه ولديه احساس قوي جدا
بالواجب الذي قام به حتى في ذلك الوقت وهو
يدرك ان دوره المستقبلي سيكون ملكا
لبريطانيا الحديثه يعرف عن الملك تشارلز
انه من اشد المهتمين بالثقافه العربيه
والاسلاميه في الغرب ويعتبر هذا الاهتمام
جزءا من رؤيته الشامله للتعيش والتفاهم
بين الثقافات المختلفه وهو من الداعمين
للحوار الدولي بين الاديان كاحد الوسائل
الفعاله لتعزيز السلام والتعاون بين
الشعوب
اتذكر محاضره القاها الملك عن الاسلام
والغرب في اكتوبر عام 93 واست فيها تعبيرا
عربيا يقول الذي يخرج من القلب يدخل القلب
والذي يخرج من اللسان لا يتجاوز الاذان
والقوه الحقيقيه لتلك المحاضره انها جاءت
من القلب وما كان يلفت انتباهنا هو اننا
لا نستطيع ان نعيش في سوء الفهم بين
العالمين الاسلامي والغربي والصور النمطيه
عن بعضنا البعض في اول زياره خارجيه لاحد
افراد العائله الملكيه البريطانيه منذ
جائحه كورونا زار الملك تشارلز رفقه
قرينته الملكه كاميلا
واتفقد اثارها التاريخيه والجامعه الازهر
كما سبقت زيارته لمسجد الشيخ زايد في اطار
تعزيز قيم التسامح الديني واحترام
التعدديه الثقافيه
شارك في العديد من المناسبات الثقافيه
والتراثيه العربيه ومنها مهرجان الجنادريه
بالرياض ورقص بالسيف متشحا الزي السعودي
الخاصه بالعارضه
للملك تشارلز الثالث علاقات وثيقه مع
العالم العربي
ولطالما شجع على التفاهم والاحترام
المتبادل بنى الاديان وثقافات من منطلق ان
فهم الثقافه الاسلاميه والعربيه بشكل افضل
يمكن ان يساعد على تعزيز هذا الحوار
وتعميق فهم الاخرين مصطفى زاروه العربيه
لندن
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات